in this video i explain you in a
simple way the new test the man
moved the eu test checks if there is a
difference between two independent
groups so if you
hate two independent groups and want to check
if there is a difference between
these two groups then you can
use the dealer js now
you rightly say the same thing does
the test for independent samples that also
checks whether there is a difference
between two independent groups
the minute you test is the non-
parametric counterpart to the offender is
for independent samples between the
two tests  But there is an
important difference the test for
independent samples checks if there is
a mean difference so
if we have our two groups
we calculate the mean of both
groups and check if this
mean differs so we
check the mean difference in
blushing the eu test on the other hand  check  n
we whether there is a slow
difference what does that mean now if we have
two groups we check whether there is
a difference in the slow of
the first group and of the second
group g how do we calculate the slow for
this way with each participant in
the  group the rank he has so
we sort all participants from
lowest to highest value this
person has for example the lowest
value this person has the second best value
this person has the third lowest value
this the four lowest value and so
on and so forth it will be
then we can simply
add up the ranks of 1 groups and
compare the ranks to each person who has assigned the rank they have
in this case we get a
slow of 42 and in this
case we get a slow of 36 don't
worry we'll do that in a moment  to be
more precise, the huge advantage is that
if you don't look at the mean
value difference, but at the run
sums  the data is then not normally
distributed
in the android new test, the data
does not have to be stored in a distribution form and
therefore it does not have to be normally
distributed.
You would do it on the other hand, as we know
, the data must be normally distributed
like my variables are installed for
the new test once  do i need a
nominal or original variable with
two characteristics, for example the
gender male and female or
if i test a drug i have
a group with drug and a
group with the placebo or the
production plant production plant a
and b
these are all nominal of the original
variables with  two characteristics
this is the independent variable then
you still need a metric or
original variable because i have to
slowly form there are of course
places of learning
here you can take the salary, for example
, the well-being or the
weight so we then have the
dependent variable short version for  the
nude  It needs a nominal or
original variable with two characteristics
and a metric or nominal one
but what exactly are the
requirements for the magic new test? The
requirements are: There must only be
two independent random
samples with at least original scaled
characteristics  so on the one hand
we need two independent
random samples that have at least original
scaled characteristics and that is
practical the variables do not have to
fulfill a defense curve therefore
whenever a normal distribution is not
given and we can therefore not calculate a culprit
who is more in red
news tests  used so we can
now come to the hypotheses the null
hypothesis is in the population
, the sum of the race
places in the two groups does not differ, so
in the population there is no
difference and the difference
is determined according to that  eight that the sum of the
ranks
are the alternative hypothesis is in the
population the sum of the ranks differs in the two
groups therefore the new hypothesis is there
is no difference and the
alternative hypothesis is there is a
difference
so and now let's go again  be more
specific about what to say exactly now place
means i have looked at an
example
you have measured the reaction time of a
small group of men and women
and want to know whether there is a
difference for this you have entered the
values ​​in a table on
the  on one side you have the sex
with female and male and on the
other side you have the values ​​for the
reaction time the disadvantage is now
this data is unfortunately not normally
distributed so we can not
use a perpetrator and we now calculate the make
you test how do we go  for this
first of all he offered every worth a
run to so let's see what is de  r
smallest value the smallest value is 33 he
gets the rank first then
let's see what is the second value that
it 430 he gets the beginning of the 2 then
let's look at the third place
that is 35 he gets the rank
three four five and  so on and so forth
that we have assigned a long place
to each value 45 is the highest value
therefore it gets the rank eleventh so
now we have defined all ranks
now we can simply add up all the ranks of the
female persons and
all the ranks of the males  kickers
the slope sum is abbreviated with tee
and we get t 1 for female with
247 the 19
the 5 and that makes 37 we do the same
for the male
participants here we get eleven to 13
six to eight that is 29
again to repeat  below zero
hypothesis is that both rank sums are
equal the alternative hypothesis is
the two slow are not equal so
now of course we want the
ph value b for this  calculations so let's
continue now we have calculated
the rank sum for the female participants
and we have the number of
cases of six therefore we have six
female test subjects that once
so that clock for the female
participants we can now
calculate here using this formula  we n 1 and
2 i.e. the number of cases of female
and male plus the rank total of the
female participants
if we use this we get a
u1 of 14
we now do exactly the same
for the male participants as a number for the male participants
from 5 and a slow 2 from 29 here
we can calculate that u2 again with the
same formula only that we
now have split up here and not 1
1 and of course here t2 in our case
16 comes out so we have now calculated u1 and
u2  that for courage it
now results from the smaller value of
the two, so in our case we take
the minimum of 14  and 16
this is of course 14
next we have to
calculate
the expected value of the clock which we get by n1 n2 divided by two
in our case this results in six times
five divided by two and that is
easily 15 last but not least we still need the
standard error from the  standard error
can be calculated using this formula
and in our case the result is 5.47 72
with all these values ​​we can now
calculate that z the time
value results from usa divided by
zach times from in our case it comes
out 14 -15 divided by 6.472 what  minus 0.18
25 results so now we have the time
value and with the time value we can
now guess the pw
so our zr gives you minus 0.18 25
for this value the corresponding value can now
be calculated depending
on the size of the sample
for the rest it is
calculated in a different way for up
to 25 cases the exact values
that can be read from a table
are
used for large random samples the
no  rmal distribution
can be used as an approximation, so in the present
example you would actually use the exact
values ​​here we still go
the way via the usa division for
this we can simply go to datatec
or use any other
calculator that calculates the ph value for us for a recipe
we only need to carry the c parties
of -0 18 25 and then we get the
pi worth out of 08 55
if we assume that we have previously defined
a significant level of 0.05, as is usually the
case, then
this value is of course larger than that
previously defined significance level
therefore the p value of 0.85 5 is significantly
greater than the significance level of
0.05 and therefore the new hypothesis can
not be rejected on the basis of this sample
again as a reminder
the ph value is greater than that
significance level the new
hypothesis is not rejected if the
ph value is lower than the significance
level
then the  new hypothesis discarded
so and now i'll tell you again
the male user is very easy to
calculate online can
simply go to ttp click on the statistics
calculator and now you can
copy your own data into this table of
the balls learn and your
own example data  take and
impression your influences post just
click on this tab of the square
terra nova let's now calculate the variables of
reaction time and gender we don't want to
calculate the parametric test
we don't want to calculate a test for independent
samples because our data are
n't normally distributed so
let's just do that  on top of
that and datatec calculates the more in new test
here we see the results for the
new test here you also get
a summary in words i hope
you liked the video and we'll see
you next time